okay so Jake is everything like with  Lena hydras definitely come to this  quarter bags and coached in major  trouble me rush just a quarter yeah I  know right hey wait Tommy hurts I'll  look it up all better feeling good and  now you're ready to enjoy a mini vacay  every day of the week don't forget the  sunscreen you got all that we are so DIY  right now it's not bad hmm we can do  better I got you what time my pic and so  see up again three well hello babe I'm  internet famous Oh awesome you said  three clock yes three go go that was  mental questioning oh oh you may and  cheers again for the advice about Ellie  think we're gonna work things through  after all just take some listening and  understanding bro don't be afraid to be  vulnerable you're right mate tough it  out all right talk to you later how long  have you been sitting there long enough  to notice the soft sensitive side of  fragma stir 3000  you